it's time to fall in love with your
carpet again and experience the feeling
of cleanliness let's welcome back ben
mckee from xero res las vegas who are
sponsoring this segment to show us the
way his brother doug is here as well
it's good to see you guys good to see
you jc so what is the zero res
difference you know the difference that
we make you got to understand carpet
cleaning it hasn't changed in nearly 80
years they're still cleaning with soaps
they're still putting detergents in
their carpets and what that does is it
makes your carpets crunchy make some
soil faster so zero res we've created a
zr water technology it's gonna make your
carpet soft like they're coming fresh
from the factory it's gonna stay cleaner
longer and you're gonna love it and they
dry faster too as well that's one of
your secrets the carpet is dry you've
done my entire house the carpet is dry
so fast it does it's dry within a matter
of a few hours and it's because we're
using state-of-the-art equipment our
truck is actually powering the vacuum
our truck's engine it's it's like a 300
horsepower vacuum i love you guys are
family owned here based in las vegas why
do i feel like after you guys clean my
carpets it's more than just clean
carpets i feel like i have clean air in
the house it does you know there's
there's actually been a study out there
after proper carpet cleaning you can
actually reduce a lot of air
contaminants in your home or in your
facility and i think it's almost up to
52 reduction in airborne contaminants uh
that includes like uh bacteria viruses
all the whole nine yards so if you're
struggling with allergies you got issues
going on get your carpets clean it's the
best thing you can do because your
carpet is actually filtering the air in
your home or at your business and you
also do air ducts as well we do we clean
air ducts state-of-the-art equipment and
that um it's it's amazing it's pretty
gross what we can pull out of air ducts
and something else and you guys do as
well you do furniture so think about if
you've had your so far your couch for
how long five ten years when's the last
time someone had their sofa cleaned and
you're sitting on that thing every
single day you're taking naps you're
drooling on that thing you guys do
furniture we do we clean nearly every
surface in your home and it's crazy like
a lot of dust you know we're we live in
a very dusty climate in the desert yes
but a lot of that dust it's actually our
dead skin
so yeah you want to get it cleaned up
now best of las vegas three years in a
row three years and ago how does that in
the row how do you guys feel about that
you know
it's amazing i i think it just shows you
know like we're we're doing something
right here in vegas we've been here for
nearly 20 years yes um but yeah we love
las vegas we love and the reason why we
have that score to the best of las vegas
is we work with our team every single
day not just on the technical side of
cleaning but also just on how to
communicate how to be personable because
we're coming into your home you guys are
very friendly and we want to be friendly
and make you a raving fan let's put this
guy to work doug work your magic this is
this the proof is in the pudding right
here explain what we're going to see
here where do you guys see this so this
is our this just you know residential
carpet this is oh let me help doug here
and you can see this carpet doesn't
appear to be that soil but right away
you can see a nine-day difference we're
rinsing this with our zr water
there's no
how does it smell jc do we just come
spray some crazy chemicals no it's clean
it's a clean scent it's not even a scent
it's a clean feeling
and that that's one of the things like
all these other companies are using
synthetic deodorizers to help cover up
the mask you know like make it smell
clean yes clean really doesn't have a
smell it's just you can see this right
here look at the difference this is just
two swipes the zero rest difference now
listen i got white carpets in my house
i've got two dogs we've got two horses
my carpets get dirty all the time and
you guys get them spotless it's amazing
you guys are unreal what you guys do
well thank you and we have some specials
too right now thank you guys for joining
us we really appreciate it hey jake
thank you chris always good to see you
doug thank you ben and give zero res a
call at
per room 702-840-3333
receive free tile cleaning of 100 square
feet minimums apply